The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, so
this brief reminder here
is about the basic requirements
in this course, which
are that we have
two written reports.
And that's the main thing I want
to remind you of, one in vision
and one in audition.
And I presume all of you
have the syllabus that
was a hand out.
And in that syllabus--
and if you don't have it,
we can provide you, of
course, with a copy.
And on the second
page of the syllabus,
it says written
report, vision part,
and this report is one that is
based on an article published
many years ago, which is
very influential article back
in 1967 about the so-called
accessory optic system.
And what I would like you to
do is to read that article
but then proceed
through the internet
to see what have become
the most recent discoveries
about the so-called
accessory optic system.
And that's what your
report needs to be about.
You can be reasonably
summary about it
so that you don't need
to write 50 pages.
But you know, you can
write this whole thing up
in four or five pages,
taking into account
as I've said what
has been discovered
since those days about the
so-called accessory optic
system.
The reason I thought this would
be a good assignment because it
will give you a good historical
sense of how knowledge has
expanded, in this
case, since the 1960s,
in uncovering yet
another attribute
that you have in the
visual system that
starts with a specialized
set of cells in the retina
and then proceeds through
a special series of steps
until it connects with
the ocular motor system.
So anyway, that's the task.
And that will consist
of 10% of the report,
of your total grade.
And the same thing is
10% also for addition.
Then the midterm exam
is going to consist
of 25% of your exams.
And the final exam is a total
55, a which 15 is vision
and 40 is audition.
So if you add them all up,
you have an equal distribution
in percentages for
vision and for audition.
So that then is
the basic layout.
And so what I would like
you to start thinking about
is how you're going to
put this report together.
I was hoping that perhaps you
could get it done by midterm.
But I don't have a hard
and fast rule about that.
As long as you get it in before
the final exam, that's fine.
But it may make
life easier if you
can start working on that while
we are talking about vision,
rather than waiting
until we are covering
the auditory system
in the course.
Does anybody have any questions
about this basic layout?
OK.
All right, now
today we are going
to talk about form perception.
Let me say one more thing,
that next time as you have it
on the syllabus, we are going
to be covering illusions.
I think that'll be fun.
You'll see all kinds of
interesting illusions
and some inferences
as to what we
think about how those
illusions come about by virtue
of the fact that there are
all sorts of interesting rules
and facts about how the
visual system works.
And then during the second
half over the next lecture,
this is this coming
Wednesday, we
are going to talk about
visual prosthesis.
All right, so that
in essence what is we
are going to cover next time.
So now let's get back to today.
We are going to talk
about form perception.
This is a topic that,
even at this stage,
we still only have
rather limited knowledge
about how the brain is
capable of carrying out
the perception of form.
And we are going to look at
some inferences and some ideas
about it.
And I will also provide you with
a brief historical background.
Because this has been a
topic of tremendous interest
for people for centuries,
trying to understand just
how we are capable of seeing
forms, shapes, patterns.
All right, so the
first influential idea
that emerged about this
is called structuralism.
And this idea actually took
place in the late 19th century.
And one of the prime proponents
was a fellow called Titchener.
And they had, in trying to come
to grips with how we do this,
had a rather basic
idea, much like building
a house with bricks.
The idea was that
perception is an aggregate
of simple elements.
We just have a whole bunch of
elements that you put together.
And that generates a
more complex precept, OK.
The problem with this approach,
well, the first problem
was that they began
to do experiments.
And they asked subjects
to try to divorce
a personal impression of
anything they looked at.
But to sort of
physically describe it.
So for example, if you
looked at an apple,
how do you have the
idea that it's an apple?
And so they said, well,
it has say, four colors.
And so the person would
list four colors and said
would have several shades.
And put all those
together, add them all up,
and that equals apple.
Well, that was the idea then.
And when they did
this systematically,
and the thing became
almost ridiculous.
Because they came up
with more than 40,000
elementary sensations,
thinking that somehow you
puts these elementary
sensations together,
40,000 of them,
and that gives us
a sense of an apple,
or banana, or whatever.
Now as soon as this sort
of became well known,
a lot of opposition arose.
And one of the most
famous ones then
was the opposition
that was brought
about by Gestalt psychologists.
And the first consideration that
I want to sort of bring up here
is a rather simple picture.
Here's a picture
everybody looks at that.
OK, what did you see there?
You saw a car, right?
Now if you look at it,
I mean this is actually
a picture of a car,
all right, but it's
interrupted by all these
vertical bars here.
And yet we're able to
infer that it's a car.
And so the question comes
up, how do you do this?
I mean, you can't simply
just add up a bunch of bricks
and say it's a car.
Because there's all
this interruption.
And most things that
we see in the world,
we see in a
discontinuous fashion.
And as a result of this,
the Gestalt psychologists,
which happened sort
of in the 1920s,
began to think about
this whole problem
in a very different way.
And they made a
tremendous influence.
And they came up
with these new ideas
of how we create the
perception of form.
The founder of the
Gestalt psychology
is a fellow called
Max Wertheimer.
So now, you can look this
up in Wikipedia, by the way,
if you look at
them more closely,
they came up with a few basic
principles of organization.
And they call this grouping.
They argue that in the brain,
somehow we group things up.
And one of the things we group
has to do with proximity.
Another one has to
do with similarity,
another one with common motion,
another one with closure,
and another one with
figure-ground perception.
This last one I'm going to talk
about at the end of today's
presentation.
But now I'm going to give you
an example of these top two.
All right, so the most
important conclusion
that they had come to which was
very much against structuralism
is that the whole
that you see is
different from the
sum of its parts.
Somehow, there is
an active process
that creates our ability to
see something that is not
evidenced from its
individual parts.
Now here is an example of
what these principles are.
Grouping by proximity, so
here we have a bunch of dots.
And if you'll put them
closer together vertically,
you see a bunch of
vertical lines essentially.
And if you put them closer
together horizontally,
you see a bunch
of vertical lines,
horizontal lines,
vertical lines.
Yeah?
So we group things
due to proximity.
Another reason we group
things is shown here,
is we group things according to
shape, or similarity of shape,
I should really say.
And here what we
have, you can readily
see a group of nine disks here,
and a group of nine triangles.
And if they're not all
the same as down here,
then you have much more
difficulty grouping it.
So there's a strong tendency
that we group things together
that are similar.
So these are some
general principles
of how we organize
our visual percepts.
So now we can look at some
more of these examples.
In doing this, we
are now going to try
to be able to say a bit
more about the brain itself.
And in doing so, it's evident
that the three major theories
that try to deal with how
the brain does it, according
to the first of
these, form perception
is accomplished by neurons
that respond selectively
to line segments of
different orientations.
Now that theory,
obviously, is the outgrowth
of what we talked about when it
was discovered that in V1, we
have orientation
selected neurons.
And this orientation
selectivity is something
that you see in
several progressively
higher visual areas, as if
everything in the world out
there was broken down into
oriented line segments, which
are then somehow put together
according to there orientation
to enable us to see shapes.
So that's one theory.
Another theory is that form
perception is accomplished
by spatial mapping of the visual
scene onto the visual cortex.
And I will elaborate
on each of these.
And the third theory is one that
form perception is accomplished
by virtue of Fourier analysis.
So let us first then
turn to form perception,
supposedly based on breaking
down the visual scene
into oriented line segments.
Now, one of the big
problems with this
is that when you look
at a famous art work
that you see in every day
in the Wall Street Journal,
there is an artist who
created this originally.
And he created faces
like this using only dots
and varied the spatial
frequency of the dots,
as you can see here.
This happens to be a
person called Larry Poons.
I'm sure none of you
have heard of him.
But here was one of the
pictures many years ago
in the Wall Street Journal.
And even today, as I say, you
can see faces created this way.
And you can readily
recognize them,
even though there are no
oriented line segments here.
And in fact, if you sort
of squint up and you three
quarter ways close your
eyes, so you can't even
see the dots anymore,
you can still
make out that face
very, very clearly.
That's because the spatial
frequency effect here
is very important,
and the degree
of shading, meaning that
this involves rather low
spatial frequency
analyses, rather than
the analysis of particular
orientations of line segments.
Now this particular
analysis has its counterpart
in the observation that
many of you have seen.
When you look at a person's
face on television,
and they want to
prevent you from being
able to see that face because
it's confidential or something,
what do they do?
Anybody remember?
What you do is
you put up a bunch
of squares of different
spatial frequencies.
And each square is comprised
of the mean illumination
level of the actual face.
If you do that, this high
frequency information
is something that
interferes with your ability
to analyze face.
So to give you an example
of this, I'm sure all of you
have seen this, but
mainly I show you this.
Here we have this example.
How many of you can tell
who these people are here?
I guess nobody can, right?
Now then what we
can do is we can
increase the frequency of these.
Here it is.
And it's still very
difficult to tell.
And now I'm going to show
you the actual photograph.
And what I'm curious about is
how many of these two people
you actually know.
I can tell you
right away, they're
extremely famous
actors and actresses.
Who recognizes these people?
How many of you recognize?
Let me see your hand.
Only a few people recognize it.
That's how quickly time goes by.
These were the most central,
most exciting, best known
people in the movies.
And this is Humphrey
Bogart, Ingrid Bergman.
OK, so these are these
two very famous people
whose faces were obstructed
by this and by this using
these high contrast edges
that obscure your ability
to smoothly analyze faces.
So that then suggests that this
idea that we extensively use
oriented line segments
to analyze faces at least
is an insufficient
explanation of how
the brain processes shapes.
Now another idea is so-called
topographic mapping.
This idea I'm sure
you can already
reject on the basis
of what I told you
about how the visual
system is laid out.
But now I'm going
to belabor that
so that you can
follow it closely.
Here we have a
runner, of course.
And here we have a monkey brain
to make it easy to understand.
And the idea here there is
that this image, once it
was discovered that the
visual field is laid out
topographically in
the visual cortex,
the idea was that what
happens is somehow,
and I may be am unfair
to poke fun of it,
but the idea is
that the mind can
look at the creation of this
image on the cortical surface
there.
And thereby, it can identify.
OK, it's almost
like a photograph,
looking at a photograph.
In this case the mind looks at
the photograph, so to speak,
on the cortical surface.
So they thought at
the time is that this
is what you have there, OK.
That's the imprint
of this image.
And indeed, you say,
oh my goodness, that's
just like that.
Therefore, I can recognize that
person, and so on and so on.
Well, I mean that's a cute idea.
But then when you
take into account
this has been discovered
subsequently to these ideas,
that the topographic
layout in the visual cortex
is actually not one to one
because of the magnification
factor.
So let's look at
that in some detail.
Here is an actual reconstruction
of the monkey area V1 here.
And here is the visual field.
And we are going to
put these red arrows
in the contralateral hemifield.
Now remember what
I told you before,
that if you look at
the visual scene,
you can imagine your eyes
being vertically cut in half.
And you have a nasal
and temporal hemiretina.
And the one which is
contralateral hemifield
crosses over and gets into
this half of the brain.
And this one crosses
over to that half.
So now if you do this and
take the magnification factor
into account, you
look at these arrows,
which are all
identical in size, OK.
There are one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven of them.
What you can see here
is the actual impression
on the cortical
surface of the neurons
that are being activated
by this look like this,
nothing like those arrows there.
And in fact, the central
arrow is much bigger
because of the huge
magnification factor.
Now this is already
creates a major problem
in trying to believe in
that particular theory,
the topographic mapping theory.
But now, if instead,
you put those arrows
halfway across each of
the hemispheres like that,
then whatever is on
this side goes here.
Whatever is on this
side goes there.
And this is the impression
that is created.
And my goodness, you
create that impression.
And you say to yourself, my god.
If that's the case,
how come I can
see seven straight
arrows of equal size
when this is the impression that
is being created in the brain?
So therefore, obviously, they
are not using a topographic map
to analyze the
visual scene at all.
Now this can be driven
home even further.
Let me make another point here.
Here we have a monkey visual
cortex again from the rear.
Here is the visual
field laid out.
And if here we put in a bunch
of dots in a circular fashion,
this is the activation there.
Now you say, oh, that's not bad.
That looks like a circle.
But then if you put it along
the midline, half and half,
then this is the
actual activation.
But you still see a circle,
even though the activation,
in terms of the topography,
is nothing like a circle.
So that indeed created a
much, much greater degree
of skepticism
among investigators
to try to understand
how we process shape.
Now let me make one
other point here,
which is a wonderful
story, which
I think will be good
for you to remember.
That's called the
Giotto story, which
says that when Pope
Benedict, that was
in the 12th century,
or the 13th century,
he set out to have the walls
of the great cathedral of Saint
Peter in Rome redecorated.
And so he sent out a
bunch of messengers
to various artists
in Italy and asked
them to provide some
of their best work
so he could evaluate
it and could
pick one guy to actually
do the redecoration.
Well, one of these messengers
went to Ambrogio Bondone Giotto
and asked him, he was
a well known artist,
and asked him to provide
a painting of his,
a drawing of his.
And Giotto said,
oh, my goodness.
I just don't have
anything around.
But I tell you what I'll do.
He took out a red pen and
drew a perfect circle, OK.
And so the messenger
took this to the pope.
And the pope said, my god.
I can't believe how
incredible this is.
And so Giotto got the
job of redecorating
the cathedral of Saint Peter.
To this day, there is
this expression in Italy,
in Tuscany in Italy, which
says the round O of Giotto, OK.
So this is the
round O of Giotto,
which somehow, in a sense,
denotes perfection, perfection
in sight and in perfection
in your ability of execution
in terms of a
drawing, for example.
All right, now to highlight
this even further,
let me point out
this to you here.
What we have here is a bunch of
imperfect circles, one of which
is perfect.
So if you keep
looking around, you
should be able to
spot which one it is.
And you should tell me what
letter denotes that circle.
Which one is a perfect circle?
AUDIENCE: C.
PROFESSOR: Very good, all right.
So we are incredibly good.
There's a slight difference
here, OK, or even slight
difference here.
And yet, we can see this
very slight difference.
And we can tell what
a perfect circle is.
I mean, that's incredible
given how the impressions are
made by those circles
on the visual cortex.
So that is an
incredible puzzle of how
we are capable of doing this.
And I'm afraid,
even to this day,
we don't have a really good
answer of how this happens.
OK, now the third theory
that has become actually
probably right now, one of
the most successful ones,
it claims that you
analyze the visual scene
by taking into account the
spatial frequencies that
are impinging on the retina, OK.
This was created by Fergus
Campbell and John Robson,
very influential.
And they pointed out, first of
all, that a very interesting
finding, which I think
I've mentioned once
before, that if you vary the
spatial frequency [? both, ?]
as well as the contrast, we
have this sensitivity function
like this.
I did show you a picture
of it the last time.
And then, furthermore,
what they had shown
is that you can create all
kinds of complex precepts
by varying the gratings.
Make them simple gratings,
compound gratings,
and compound gratings
with much lower contrast.
And this is simple different
spatial frequencies.
These are compound.
And these, as I've said, are
lower spatial frequencies.
So then if you again
squint, then you
will see something
much smoother.
So they actually carried out a
detailed mathematical analysis
using Fourier analysis.
And what they did
was quite remarkable.
They would down break
down a visual scene,
like a photograph of New
York with all the skylights,
OK, skyscrapers.
And then they would convert
that using Fourier analysis.
And they could recreate
the visual scene
with a high degree of
accuracy using that procedure.
Now if indeed the
visual system uses this,
you have a number of basic
logical requirements.
And those basic logical,
let me come back to that,
the basic logical
requirements are
that you need spatial
frequency analysis.
And I've shown you that already
when we talked about V1,
that neurons there are
spatial frequency selective.
Secondly, that there
are contrast selective,
which you know already.
And of course, the
orientation selective,
and they can tell
you about phase.
As long as you have
these four attributes,
you can perform a
detailed Fourier analysis
to reconstruct the visual scene.
So now to stress
this even further,
they did a series of
experiments, in which they
asked a question,
is it true that you
have a particular spatial
frequency analysis,
that you can manipulate that?
And so they did an
experiment, which
called a frequency-specific
adaptation experiment.
They would present to
a subject this display
and have the subject look at
this for a couple of minutes
without having to fixate.
And then they would
look at each of those.
And they found that this, which
is the same spatial frequency,
they had difficulty seeing
because of this adaptation.
And so then they did a
series of careful studies
and carried out this
analysis and showed
that you could get any
kind of spatial frequency
to lose your sensitivity
for it if you
had been pre-exposed to it.
So that's what that looked like.
And by doing this
systematically,
they came up with
the idea that what
you have in the visual cortex
is a series of channels
that are spatial
frequency-selective.
And I showed you
we talked about V1,
that indeed, there are neurons
there that are selected
to particular
spatial frequencies.
And they proposed that you have
a series of channels like this,
OK, that peak at different
spatial frequencies.
And by activating
them selectively,
you can reconstruct
virtually anything out
in the visual scene
using Fourier analysis.
Now OK, I think that then is
the essence of that theory.
And I can tell you that some
people avidly believe in it.
And there are some people
who are highly skeptical.
I'm not sure where I stand
at this stage about that.
But now, people began
to study our shape,
the ability to see shapes by
recording various visual areas.
And I want to tell you next
about some studies that
had been done primarily
in Japan looking
at inferotemporal cortex,
which is [INAUDIBLE] already
mentioned that to be involved
in the analysis of shapes
and in particular, in the
analysis of faces as well.
So what these
investigators did is
they would record to
individual neurons
in inferotemporal cortex.
And when they did that, they
would present various stimuli
to see how those
cells responded.
And they found, they
claimed to find,
that there was some
incredible specificity
in inferotemporal
cortex for shapes.
And so what they did,
here's an example.
Here, we have the neurons'
responses, histograms.
And on top, above it, we
have the particular shape
that was presented repeatedly.
So this particular cell
responded vigorously to this,
but very poorly to that,
and so on down the line.
But you can see
that it responded
to several different shapes,
quite well to this one,
reasonably well to that one,
so a whole range of them.
So it wasn't like this
particular neuron responded
only to one particular shape.
But that idea that
you have neurons
which are specific
for certain shapes
did take on a lot of attraction
on part of investigators.
And some of them
indeed thought that you
have these neurons
which are selective
to individual elements
in the visual scene.
And those subsequently
the critics refer to
as your having
grandmother cells.
Somewhere in the
brain there's a cell
that represents your
grandmother, all right.
Now that idea was
disabuse subsequently.
But it took very stronghold
in many investigators' minds.
And here's another
example of yet
another inferotemporal
neurons, in this case again
for various shapes, showing
that this shape was,
elicited a lot of responses,
as well as did this.
The rest of them didn't
respond, didn't elicit as much
of a response.
So these kinds of
experiments then,
they tried to systematize.
And they came up with an idea
which, at least to my mind,
borders on the absurd,
which is shown here.
Here is a section of
inferotemporal cortex.
And they argue that
they are columns there,
and that these columns
represent different percepts.
So here we have a
bunch of percepts
that process the monkey.
This is a monkey, of course,
that process monkey faces.
And by inference,
therefore, there
must be some areas in
inferotemporal cortex
that process human
faces in humans.
And then others process
different aspects
of the visual scene.
Now the big problem, technical
problem, with this approach
is that when you record
from individual neurons,
all right, typically
in these experiments,
you can study a single neuron
for a fairly limited time,
not like for months on end, just
maybe a few hours or something.
And so because of
that, you can only
present a limited number
of visual stimuli.
Now there are millions of
visual stimuli out there.
And so to really establish how
specific this particular neuron
is, they say well, these are
the only shapes it's showing us.
What if you use the
cross, or who knows,
many, many other
things, something
that is three dimensional?
How would these cells respond?
And so these cells respond
to different degrees,
to hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of different stimuli.
And the real fact then is
that anytime a stimulus
appears out there, you're
activating tens of thousands
of neurons, maybe even
more, in the visual system.
And each of those
neurons, especially
in inferotemporal cortex,
responds to different degrees
to the different stimuli.
It is the compendium of these
many, many neurons firing
into different degrees
to different stimuli
that gives you sort of an
overall computational ability
to say what that stimulus is.
Now to be able to analyze
that, it is that complicated,
that really takes
a lot of effort.
Now some people are
now trying to do this.
And the way you
try to do this is
that you're recording
from hundreds and hundreds
of neurons with
multiple electrodes,
present various scenes.
And you see how these neurons
respond as an aggregate,
so that you can determine
whether or not there is indeed
the potential for some
sort of computation
that takes place in
gaining the impression
of a particular individual face.
Now one of the very
important facts
here is, of course, that as you
look around the visual scene,
let's imagine you're
looking at a face.
You're looking at
a face head on.
You're looking at a
face in a profile.
You're looking at a face tilted.
You're looking at a face close.
You're looking at a face far.
And it's still
all the same face.
And yet the
impressions that face
makes on the visual
system, in the retina,
in the geniculate, in the visual
cortex, varies a great deal.
And yet we can come
up with constancy,
which is sort of a
higher level process.
And I'll come to
that in short order.
All right, so now,
therefore, we need
to start to talk about what we
call intermediate level vision.
What is intermediate
level vision?
So far, we've talked
almost exclusively
about basic visual capacities,
color, brightness, pattern,
texture, motion,
depth, the very,
just the very basic types.
But now when we talk about
intermediate visual capacities,
we talk about constancy.
One example of
constancy, of course,
is that the face that
you're looking at,
whether it's profile, or head
on, or near, or far, it's
still the same face.
So we get constancy out of it.
Then there's an
important necessity
to be able to select
various aspects out
of the visual scene, to be
able to select if you recognize
things, to induce
transposition and variance,
and to be able to
make comparisons,
and also lastly, to be able to
say where things are in space.
So those are these
intermediate capacities.
And we'll talk a little
bit about them next.
All right, so here's an
example of constancy.
What we have here
is a bunch of words
for doubt in different
sizes, and orientations,
and some handwritten, and so on.
And yet all of them say
the same thing, doubt.
We extract that, OK.
Now to make this
even more difficult,
I'm going to tell you that
there's one of these words here
which is not doubt
and see who can
find the word that is not doubt.
Everybody find it yet?
OK, right there, not
doubt but doubts.
And so we are able to
extract the difference
in this kind of
visual scene, even
though it is incredibly subtle.
And yet, we are also able
to say that this doubt,
and this doubt, and this
doubt are all the same,
even though they're different
size or different in print.
We can extract from
that the common element.
So this is an
incredible capacity
on part of the visual system.
And of course, the big question
comes up, how is this achieved?
And at this stage, we only
have very preliminary answers
to that.
OK, so now I want to show you a
couple other cute things here.
This is another famous
artist, Hirschfeld,
He is no longer with
us, unfortunately.
He published hundreds
of these little cartoons
in The New Yorker, all right.
Now, you see his named
here, Hirschfeld.
What do you see at
the end of his name?
What's that-- what is this?
What, that?
Huh?
A number three.
Why does it say
Hirschfeld three?
His name isn't Hirschfeld three.
And then if you've
seen several of these,
how many of you have
seen these before?
Oh, you missed out on
something very good.
At least look it up sometimes
again on the internet.
Just type in Hirschfeld.
And some of these will come up.
So he says three.
And some of his
pictures may have one.
Some of his pictures may
have five or six at the end.
And you say, well,
what on earth is that?
Anybody know?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't he have other
names hidden in the images?
So maybe that's the [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ah ha,
you're thinking well.
OK, that's getting there.
OK, so he's telling us
something that there
are three of in this picture.
That's what he's telling us.
OK.
So what is the three of
that he has in this picture?
Ah ha, anybody want
to come up with?
It
AUDIENCE: The line orientation?
PROFESSOR: Huh?
AUDIENCE: Like the
orientation of the line?
PROFESSOR: Orientation?
No.
Mhm.
OK, I'll give you a clue.
Hirschfeld had a daughter--
AUDIENCE: Nina.
PROFESSOR: Who he was very
fond-- hey, fantastic, Nina.
OK.
So had a daughter, Nina.
And he decided in his display
to put her name up there.
And now he said three,
that he put her name up
there three times.
Now who can find
all three of them?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the arm [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK, here's one.
Here is another one.
OK, and here is the
third one, in the arms.
And so if you, that's one of
the fun things you can do.
Back when he was
doing this actively,
every time he had a
cartoon like this,
I would spend some time trying
to see where were the Ninas.
[LAUGHTER]
So that I think is
quite remarkable
and further highlights
the complexities
and the remarkability
of our visual system.
OK, so now, I'm showing
you yet another picture.
In this case again,
you have to be
knowledgeable about something.
Does anybody know who this is?
Oh, all right.
Well, let me see if
I make it smaller.
Can you see that now?
Who is that?
OK, that's Voltaire.
All right.
Now Voltaire, 18th century, is
a guy who had outdone all of us.
And he had written 2,000 books.
Can you believe that?
The guy had written 2,000 books.
But that's not the
prime point here.
Most of us who know a
little bit about history
immediately recognize him
as, oh yeah, that's Voltaire.
But then if you go back here and
you look at this more closely,
and so what I'm going
to do here is just
to tell you what a
remarkable artist.
The guy who did this
is Salvador Dali.
This, by the way,
is his wife, OK.
And so what I'm
going to do here,
I'm going to blow up the
center portion of this figure.
There it is.
Can you see this?
This is two faces, two nuns.
And this is their outfit.
So there's nothing there
that is really Voltaire.
But he's such a
remarkable artist
that he could create Voltaire
by playing around with this, OK.
So let me go back to
the display again.
OK, so this is Salvador Dali.
And certainly, it's an
artist who is remarkable.
He has many paintings
in which this kind
of a double confusing thing,
playing on your ability to see.
So because of that,
for people like me
who's interested in
how we see things,
certainly I'm very
intrigued by his artwork.
And you may enjoy looking
that up again on the internet.
OK, so now I'm going to tell you
yet another interesting aspect
of art involved in this.
And this one has to do with a
book, a very clever book that
was written by David Hockney.
Has anybody ever heard of him?
I'm not surprised since
he's not that well known.
But the book he wrote is
called Secret Knowledge.
Now what was that all about?
Well, he analyzed how artists
created paintings way,
way, way back when and
in subsequent years
up to the present.
And now I'm going to show
you some of his pictures
and give you a sense of
what this is all about.
Here is a picture, OK, by
Masolino da Panicale in 1425.
This was a typical kind
of picture back then.
Artists had a very
poor sense of how
to create depth
perception in a painting.
That was before they came
up with vanishing point.
And so this kind of looks flat
and fairly expressionless.
This was in 1425.
And then Hockney noticed
that just five years later,
another artist came
up with a picture,
just five years later, that
looks almost like a photograph.
And he said, what on
earth has happened?
And that's why the book is
called the Secret Knowledge.
So what happened?
Anybody know?
Ah, all right.
Well, let me tell
you what happened.
What happened is that at
that time, in the 1400s,
they came up with the lens, OK.
And so they created a device
called the camera obscura.
Does anybody know what
the camera obscura is?
It's essentially very
similar to a camera, OK.
So here we have it.
Here's a camera obscura.
And what they did,
these artists,
they would create a building.
So it will be dark inside.
And then they would
put the lens here.
And they would put
some object out here
that they wanted to
make a painting of.
And that would be reflected
onto a piece of canvas here.
Of course, it would
be upside down, right?
And then they would paint it.
And so once it was painted,
they could turn it around
and finish it and sell it.
Now, the reason they did this,
the prime reason they did this,
is because it was much
much, much quicker
to create a portrait,
for example,
by using this procedure than
to actually look at a person
and paint them on the
canvas while looking at it.
OK.
So that was done.
And of course, this was
sort of a no, no thing.
And because of that,
it was kept secret.
All these artists who did this,
and some very famous artists
did so, were very careful
never to disclose to the public
that they did this
kind of thing.
Because it was conceived to be
kind of a cheating thing, OK.
So what happened then was
that all these paintings were
created.
And here's an example
by van Eyck in 1436.
Again, this looks much
like a photograph.
But some other thing
is a bit distorted.
So Hockney undertook a
careful, detailed analysis
of how we could tell
whether a painting was
a real painting or one that
used the camera obscura method.
And that's also a real
painting in a sense,
but a painting using the
camera obscura method.
And he came up with
a series of criteria
which are listed in the book.
But I'm only going to
deal with one of them.
OK, so here is an example.
This is in 1597.
This is by Caravaggio, OK.
And what is notable
about this person?
Well, to Hockney,
what was notable
is that this person
is holding the wine
glass in his left hand.
Yeah?
And he said, huh.
That's curious.
And then he looked at a whole
bunch of other paintings.
And he had one in
which there were
three people on the painting.
And all three of them
were left handed.
Yeah.
And he said, my god,
that is really curious.
And he said, well,
let me analyze
what happens when you
do this kind of stuff
with the camera obscura method.
So here's the example of this.
This is the original
image, he claims,
meaning the person is right
handed, is not left handed.
Then you put this
person through the lens
and put him up here
upside down like that, OK.
He's painted on the
canvas like that.
And then what you do is you
rotate this 180 degrees.
And when you do
that, lo and behold,
the person becomes left hand.
And to make this clear,
I added the F here.
So this is a normal
F. This is what
is projected onto the canvas.
And this is when you
rotate it 180 degrees.
So you reverse the left
according to Hockney,
reverse the image.
And so it was a dead giveaway
that most of the people who
appeared left handed in his
paintings, in these paintings,
I should say, not
just Caravaggio,
but several other people,
used the camera obscura method
for creating the painting.
All right, so that
is the process.
And then I want to show you
one more example of this.
OK, this is a very famous
painting also, all right.
This is the so-called marriage
of Giovanni Arnolfini.
And this by van Eyck, again
1493, way, way, way, way, way,
way back then.
Now this is a famous painting.
Now there's one
interesting thing
first of all I
want to point out.
You see this here?
That's proof that
in those days they
had come up with the lens, yeah.
Now what is wrong
with this picture?
This guy who is about
to marry this woman
is holding her
with his left hand.
I mean, that's unacceptable.
You're supposed to hold it
with the right hand, yeah.
Now the reason he's holding
it with the left hand
is because the artist, van
Eyck, used the camera, according
to Hockney, used the camera
obscura method to take this,
to paint this picture, OK.
And then he rotated
180 degrees and became,
he became left
handed as a result.
Now if instead of having
done that, you would go back,
you don't have to go back.
Go back to here, and
let's go back to this.
If you take this guy here
and you create the picture.
But then instead of rotating
it, if you could flip it,
then you would, he will
remain right handed.
But of course, we can't do
that because it's on a canvas.
It's not on a transparency.
So that then is the
interesting story of artwork
that was created using
the camera obscura
system that further
the highlights
the amazing interestingly
complicated manner
in which we can analyze the
visual scene for shapes.
All right, now another factor
that is in a similar vein
has to do with the
recognition of faces.
Lots of experiments have
been done, including several
in our department here,
that has recognized
that, unfortunate use of
terms, recognition, recognize,
became aware of the fact that
facial recognition depends
very heavily on seeing
faces right side up.
When faces are upside down,
you have great difficulty
telling who is who, OK.
So let's do that.
Here are a bunch of faces.
And I bet you can you
can tell this one, right?
Who is it?
And who is this?
Very good.
And those two you don't know.
The problem is that I am
going to flip this over now.
And you still don't
know who those two are.
OK, so this one
is Norbert Wiener.
Now all of you know
about Norbert Wiener.
He is one of the great
geniuses of our time.
He came up with
the digital code.
He used to be a
professor at MIT.
And this here is Chuck Vest.
Anybody recognize him?
Chuck Vest was a
president of MIT for what?
For eight years, I believe,
maybe more, 12 years?
I forget.
And he has sunk into
obscurity, even though he
was incredibly visible
for many, many years.
If I had shown this to you
say eight or 10 years ago,
you would immediately
recognize him.
Because he, at that time,
was a president at MIT.
So that then is an
interesting fact
that even though we are capable
of using intermediate level
vision in a very
sophisticated way,
it does not seem to work that
well for upside down faces.
You guys did pretty
good with those.
But it takes a while.
If I had flashed that
on in a tachistoscope,
you wouldn't have had a vague
idea of who those people were.
But once it's on for a while
and you can analyze it,
you can eventually tell
even an upside down face.
OK, now in the same vein
as we are talking about,
our ability to process shapes
based on contours and whatnot,
one of the interesting set of
experiments people had done
is to look at what is
called subjective contours.
And so let me give you a
couple of examples of that.
Here's an example.
Almost instantly, here
you can see a disk.
And here you can
see a square rotated
45 degrees, a
diamond if you will.
But if you analyze
this carefully,
you can see that about
80% of this border
here is not a border.
There's no border here.
There's no border here,
here, here, here, here.
And yet we can see a square.
So there's some strange ability
in part of the visual system
to complete inferred borders.
All right, I'll come back
to that in just a minute.
Now another example
of this is shown here.
Can you make out
what it says here?
If you look a little bit,
you should be able to see.
What is it?
Visual system, very good.
It was difficult to see.
But as soon as I
turn this into color,
you have no trouble at all.
And that highlights
another important reason
why color vision is so
useful and has evolved.
Because it enables
us to see borders,
where under certain conditions
and lighting conditions,
borders would not be visible
on the black and white.
OK, so now that's another
interesting example,
has to do with further
subjective contours.
And here's an example of
one with a high contrast,
where you can
readily see a cube.
Does everybody see a cube there?
All right, but if you look
here, it's next to impossible
to see that.
Because here the
stimuli are isoluminant.
So here you eliminated
contrast, which
is a very important
aspect of being
able to analyze the visual
scene in various ways,
including three dimensions.
All right, so now here's a
very interesting discovery that
was made by recording
an area, V2.
The recordings were
then made to see
whether those neurons
perceive subjective contours.
So here's a receptive field.
And you take this bar and move
it back and forth across it.
And you can see it gives
a vigorous response.
Now you do the same thing.
But you don't, here you have
only a subjective contour.
And then you move this
back and forth across.
Somehow the information is
added up from other areas,
so that this cell
responds, not that well,
but responds reasonably well
to the subjective contour.
So it's said that in
V2, you can carry out
some of these higher
level processes that
enables you to
complete figures even
when they are
incomplete like that.
OK, here's another
example of that.
This is even more dramatic.
In this case, we take this
bar back and forth across.
That's a vigorous response.
And then you do the same thing.
You create a bar here simply
by these continuous horizontal
bars.
And still, the cell
responds quite well,
as if it were
seeing an edge here.
So we have this kind of
completion in area V2.
So this is sort
of an initial hint
then that already
in area V2, you
begin to process
higher level events,
among which is the
fact that you can
complete incomplete contours.
All right, so now, the next
thing we're going to turn to,
we're going to ask
the question, when
we deal with these
so-called intermediate level
visual capacities, what
happens when you take out
such areas as V4 and
MT to your ability
to see these intermediate
visual capacities?
So let me describe
to you some of these,
how one would do
experiments like this.
First of all,
monkeys are trained.
This is done with monkeys, of
course, because we can't just
take a human and remove V4 MT.
And so what you do here is you
first present a fixation spot.
Once the monkey fixates,
you present a shape,
in this case a square.
And then you present a whole
bunch of other ones, only one
of which is the same
as the original.
And the monkey has to
make a [INAUDIBLE] there
to be rewarded.
So he has to be able to
detect identity, which
is an intermediate
visual capacity.
So that's what this is like.
And so then what
you can do here is
to vary the amount
of information
you can provide, again by
reducing the amount of contour
information that
you can provide.
You can do this in several ways.
First of all, before we do that,
I'll come to that in a second,
let's just see, how
does the monkey do
when you do those very similar
shapes I just have shown you
after you take out area V4?
What you find here is that the
monkey initially, after you
take out the area V4, can't
even do the regular task, which
is this one, right?
So this is identical to
this one in this case.
And when you do that, he does
very poorly to begin with
and then gradually,
over many, many days,
improves a great deal.
Then if you put a new figure
in, then it takes a while for it
to learn that, all right.
Now then, what you
can do, now I come
to this business of
having these same figures.
But you can vary
them now, so that you
have to do a transposition to
do an intermediate visual task.
In this case, what you do
is that you vary the size.
In this case, it's
identical just like it was.
In this case, you see that
this is smaller than this.
But you say, oh, I have
to go find the circle.
I'm not looking for identity.
I'm looking for something
that's the same looking.
And here we have
even bigger case.
This is a triangle.
And so the monkey
makes a [INAUDIBLE]
to that one here to this one.
So that has to do a
test position in size.
Another thing you can
do that we talked about,
you can vary the amount
of contour information
by doing this kind of occlusion.
And the degree of
occlusion you can
vary by varying the spatial
frequency of the display.
And lastly, you can also
decrease or increase the amount
of contour information
that you provide.
Now if you do with this, you get
a huge effect after V4 lesion.
This was the normal condition
with the varied object size.
This is the occlusion.
And here is the varied
contour information.
You can see that there is
quite a dramatic loss, not
a total, but quite a notable
loss, in the monkey's ability
to perform this task.
And this is also reflected
in the huge increase
in the latencies with which the
monkey can perform the task.
So area V4 seems to
play an important role
in these intermediate
visual capacities.
And I come to some more examples
of that in just a minute.
Now, yet another
important factor
in analyzing the
visual scene occurs
when it is our task
to find something
out there that is
less noticeable.
Remember, we talked a little
bit about using camouflage,
in which case, you have to find
something lesser to survive.
Now in this case,
what we can do here,
do a similar
experiment in a monkey.
On the left side,
the target, the one
the monkey's supposed to select,
has a much higher contrast
than the distractors.
And you can vary the
degree of difference,
but always the target is
brighter than the others,
so that it stands out.
But then, you must
be equally able,
whether you're an
animal or a human,
to be able to pull
out something that's
lesser in the visuals field.
And you have to
be able to do this
if you are going to survive
in your environment.
Now here then, the task is to
go to this lesser stimulus,
because it's the odd stimulus.
So what you're extracting
is the odd stimulus.
Here it's easy to extract, and
here it's difficult to extract.
And so now the question is what
happens in the visual cortex?
What area plays a role in this?
And so it was
discovered that area V4
is very important for this.
And let me explain
this to you then.
You do an experiment in
which you remove area V4
and see what happens.
And here what we have is
when the star gets brighter,
you vary the
luminance difference.
And you can see there's a mild
deficit with the V4 lesion,
highly significant
but still fairly mild.
On the other hand, when
you make it dimmer,
the monkey is practically
staying at the probability.
He cannot do the task at all.
So somehow, V4 plays
a very important role
in being able to ferret
out some subtle things
in the environment,
lesser things.
All right, so this
then brings us
to yet another way
of analyzing this.
We can, in this case,
go to the larger target,
in this case to
the smaller target.
And you can recognize yourself
that this is certainly
easier than that.
But a normal monkey can do
both of these quite well,
shown here.
This is the normal
monkey's performance,
the target larger, here
the target smaller.
He does extremely well.
But with a V4 lesion when
the target is smaller,
it's totally devastated, so
as if area V4 were involved
in the analysis of subtle
things, things which are lesser
then, rather than
being reflex like
and going to the brightest,
biggest thing in the world.
OK, so that then indeed
highlights the fact
that we have some
of these areas,
including V4 and of
course, therefore MT,
that involved in these much more
subtle types of visual analyses
that we need to perform.
Now capitalizing on these
kinds of subtle things
that we are capable of doing,
artists, in addition to
the ones that I've
shown you before, also
created all kinds of percepts, I
should say paintings, sketches,
precepts, that cause
confusion by playing around
with these factors.
One of these here is a very well
known audience called Escher.
This was so near the
end of the 19th century.
And here what we
have is this is sort
of a figure-ground confusion.
Here what we have is a bunch
of birds that fly to the right,
and also a bunch of birds
that fly to the left.
And so it's confusing.
It's alternating.
You don't know
which one is which.
And it has to do with a
very, very clever creation
of figure-ground confusions.
And actually, next time
we talk about illusions,
I will bring in some more of
these kinds of curious effects.
And then here's another one.
And it's very hard for you to
tell are the stairs going up?
Are they going down?
What's going on?
It's the same kind of
play with the paintings
to create confusion
in your perceptions.
And then here is
yet another one,
where you don't know
is water running up,
or is the water
running down here?
That's again an
interesting confusion
that Escher has created.
All right, so that
then is the essence
of what I wanted to
cover today to highlight
the fact that our
ability to extract shape
information in the world
is absolutely incredible.
And it has triggered
not only experiments
to try to understand
that by scientists,
but it has created a
tremendous amount of artwork
that played with these
because it was so enjoyable.
And certainly, the several
paintings that I have shown you
must have given you
a pretty good sense
of how artists capitalize on
these limitations in ability
to extract intermediate
and high level vision
capacities from
the visual scene.
All right, so to summarize
them, first of all,
I mentioned three
major theories that
have to do with form processing.
The one, the orientation
of line segments.
And I pointed out to you
that that theory is not
particularly powerful.
And then the one, the
topographic theory,
which turned out to be
bordering on the ridiculous.
And finally, Fourier
analysis, which
seems to have a lot of
power, even though it also
has created a lot of skeptics.
All right, then I pointed
out to that are the V2, V4,
and inferotemporal cortex,
play important roles
in intermediate vision, these
intermediate visual capacities
we talked about in detail.
Then I pointed out to
you also that in V2, it
was discovered that there
are some neurons that
respond to subjective contours,
indicating that already in area
V2, we can perform these
incredibly higher level
abilities to extract
information when
it is unclear in
the visual scene.
Then I pointed out to
you that recognition
of objects transformed
in the various ways
is compromised by V4 and
inferotemporal lesions.
And V4 lesions also
produce major deficits
in learning and selecting
lesser stimuli, which
is a very important
attribute for us
to be able not the respond
in reflex-like fashion
to what is most
obvious out there,
but to be able to
extract the subtle things
from the visual scene.
Some inferotemporal neurons
are selective for objects
including faces.
But most respond to a variety
of objects whose recognition is
based on the
differential activity
of a great many neurons.
OK, so that then brings me
to the last point, which
is how we process and deal
with ambiguities in perception,
unfortunately still
remains a mystery.
And so there's a lot of space
here for new investigators
to come up with exciting,
interesting new findings
about how the brain performs
these kinds of subtle analyses
of the visual scene.
OK, I think I'll leave
this until next time.
I'll talk about this next time.
OK, does anybody
have any questions?
All right, I hope that you
can take a little bit of time
out, look at some of these
artists on the internet,
and look at Hirschfeld and the
Ninas that I had shown you.